stratford-on-avon district council is
currently consulting on the site
allocations plan
this short video explains policy snap 6
in the site allocations plan which
relates to self and custom-built housing
self-built housing is where people
directly organize the design and
construction of new homes for themselves
while custom-built housing is where
individuals or groups work with a
specific developer
to build new homes that meet their
specific aspirations
in 2015 the government introduced a
requirement for councils to give
planning permission for enough plots to
meet the demand for self and
custom-built house building in their
area
since 2016 councils have been required
to keep a register of those who are
seeking plots of land
in their area for this purpose
in june 2020 stratford or nathan
district council had 151 people on its
register
with an average of 36 individuals
applying each calendar year
the policy within the site allocations
plan sets out how the need within
stratford-on-avon district
up to 2031 can be achieved
all self and custom build plots will be
offered in the first
instance to people that have a local
connection through either living
working or by having close family within
the district
the council will encourage this type of
housing to be zero carbon
with a minimum carbon reduction of 31
that can be achieved through measures
such as low
carbon heating schemes renewable energy
and better fabric standards
applicants will need to submit a
sustainability statement with their
planning applications
outlining how their development will
meet this low carbon standard
to ensure high quality developments
applicants for self and custom build
sites will be expected to prepare design
codes or plot passports
these should cover such matters as
phasing building form
density footprints of dwellings building
lines
materials boundary treatment public open
space
landscaping and waste facilities
there are three ways in which new self
and custom-built housing will be
provided
as long as they meet certain criteria
firstly as an integral part of the new
settlements at gaydon lighthound heath
and long martin airfield
secondly on suitable unallocated sites
within or adjacent to the built-up area
boundaries of settlements
thirdly on 11 sites allocated
specifically for this purpose within the
plan
there are 11 sites in the plan that are
solely allocated
for self and custom built homes all of
which lie directly adjacent to the
relevant built up area boundaries and
relate well to the physical form of the
settlement
these sites have been promoted for this
type of housing by the landowner
and you can see the full list in the
description of this video as well as in
the sap
i hope this has provided you with an
overview to our approach to meeting the
district's need for self and custom
build housing
you can find out more in the site
allocations plan and submit any comments
you have
by visiting our website at
www.stratford.org
dot uk forward slash sappo